[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue dans le débat sur france 24 la
corée du nord confirme avoir lancé son
plus puissants missiles depuis à 2017 le
pays de kim jong-un n'a jamais testé
autant de missiles en un mois qu'en ce
mois de janvier le missile a été tiré de
la province septentrionale de jacques
doo la corée du nord a lancé ce qu'elle
a présenté comme des missiles
hypersonique depuis l'investiture de joe
biden qui ont mis en garde rejeter les
différentes propositions de dialogue
faite par washington ces essais
nord-coréens interviennent alors que la
chine accueille les jeux olympiques
d'hiver à partir de vendredi et que la
corée du sud s'il ya une élection
présidentielle au mois de mars alors kim
jong-un xi jingping vladimir poutine
tous ces autocrates ont lancé des
missiles hypersonique les etats unis
sont en retard dans cette technologie la
france reste discrète alors qu'elle
menace représente la corée du nord quels
sont les objectifs de kim jong-un
comment les missiles hypersonique
relance-t-il la course aux armements on
en parle avec mes invités j'ai le
plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés jean yves
colin bonsoir soir merci être avec tout
spécialiste de l'asie du nord à les
jeunes stunter nous avons également avec
nous par skype de paris frédéric
charillon bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
professeur à l'université clermont
auvergne spécialiste des questions
internationales
auteur de guerre d' influence les états
à la conquête des esprits et c'est aux
éditions odile jacob
avec nous également par skype de
montpellier le général jean vincent
brisset bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec
nous chercheur associé à l'iris
spécialiste des questions stratégiques
et de défense en asie bienvenue à tous
les trois georges colas je voulais
démarrer par vous quelle est la ligne de
kim jong-un pourquoi autant de missiles
en si peu de temps est ce qu'il doit se
replacer dans le jeu aujourd'hui ki moon
tout d'abord là il est vrai que son
arsenal militaire son arsenal nucléaire
est en fait pour lui ça garantit
première et ça quasiment sa seule
garantie par rapport aux etats-unis ses
alliés que sont la corée du sud le japon
et peut-être même aussi par rapport à
son très proche amie line mais qui est
un ami tellement gros que ça peut
l'inquiéter également donc je pense que
l'objectif de kim jong-un en faisant ces
sept essais qui sont effectivement l'air
dessert oui cet essai en un mois alors
que randy nord en 2021 il y en a huit
pendant l'année pendant l'année voilà
donc sonia une accélération de son
accélération je pense qu'il il veut se
saisir de deux des circonstances
actuelles c'est est-ce que vous avez
indiqué les jeux olympiques mais
peut-être aussi des tensions qui
existent un peu partout dans le monde
comme l'ukraine taiwan pour essayer de
revenir sur le devant de la scène
remonte et la priorité nord-coréenne si
loisirs dans la liste de celles des
états unis et tester un peu ce que
veulent les etats-unis testés un peu ce
que veulent les états unis frédéric
charillon à ce que vous pouvez rebondir
justement se souvient du sommet trump
kim jong-un à il n'avait pas donné grand
chose ce sommet après des annonces
tonitruantes de donald trump joe biden
avait l'air plutôt ouvert au dialogue
mais le leader nord-coréen le provoque
cette fois
oui ils avaient l'air plus ouvert mais
il s'est rien passé depuis le puy un an
pratiquement depuis l'élection de
bayonne enfin depuis son entrée en
fonction avec la avec la corée du nord
et peut-être que c'est aussi une façon
pour la corée du nord de se rappeler au
bon souvenir des états unis le timing
est très important ce que vous l'avez
souligné on a à la fois les jeux
olympiques de pékin qui arrive on a plus
d'un an de benzène au pouvoir aux états
unis la corée du nord qu'on présente
souvent suis pas je parle sous le
contrôle du spécialiste de la zone moi
je suis tout à une généralisation
internationale mais dans ses processus
de négociation c'est qu'il vient de
laisser au hasard même et peut-être
surtout dans des régimes qu'on a
tendance parfois à présenter comme
irrationnel où ils ne sont pas il ya
évidemment un timing donc c'est
important que la question vous poser
c'est pourquoi maintenant alors qu'il ya
d'une part ce moment qui consiste à
rappeler aux grandes puissances chine
etats unis qui ont un peu tendance à
monopoliser les relations
internationales autour de leur bras de
fer de rappeler aux deux qu' il ya
d'autres acteurs qui sont là et qu'ils
ont les moyens de se rappeler à leur bon
souvenir donc effectivement c'est une
sorte de piqûre de rappel pour dire il
faut que tu être maintenant faire
attention à nous et nous avons les
moyens de vous y oblige et général jean
vincent brisset une sacrée piqûre de
rappel puisque à l'écouté la corée du
nord affirme avoir testé avec succès
pour la première fois un planeur
hypersonique ça c'était au mois de
septembre dernier donc ces missiles
hypersonique ce sont des missiles
particulièrement performant indétectable
alors théoriquement un missile
hypersonique c'est indétectable c'est
extrêmement difficiles à apprécier ta
détectable difficiles à détecter c'est
extrêmement difficile à intercepter même
si on réussit à les détecter mais c'est
quelque chose qui est extrêmement
complexe à mettre au point et dont la
précision est pour le moment assez
faible parce que les soumise à pas mal
d'allers ya sur le plan technique ce que
plus beaucoup d'intéressant dans les
tirs qui viennent d'être faits c'est que
ils sont sur les sept tirs il y en a au
moins cinq qui sont sur des missiles
conduit à roulettes soit sur voie
routière soit sur des trains et ça c'est
la capacité d'une frappe en seconde pour
la corée du nord donc même s'il y avait
eu une tentative de frappe de
décapitation faites par les états unis
avec ou pas l'assentiment d'une partie
de la communauté internationale la corée
la corée du nord garde la possibilité de
continuer à tirer après avoir été frappé
une première fois et donc ça en termes
de dissuasion vous dites c'est important
c'est une étape extrêmement importante
dans la dissuasion c'est l'étape dans
lequel sont passés tous les grands pays
pâtit dans les débuts c'était des
missiles en silo est la deuxième étape
c'est pour cette frappe en gros soit par
des sous-marins nucléaires lensois
vengeance est extrêmement complexe
extrêmement cher soit par ben justement
par des missiles qui sont cachés dans
une dans une grotte dans une cage dans
un bunker n'importe quoi et consorts
juste le temps de les lancer on va
évoquer voir un peu plus loin justement
sur ce que sont ces fameux missiles
hypersonique on va regarder ce reportage
de nos confrères de france télévisions
on en reparle ensuite
la russie qui se vante de maîtriser une
arme invincible
la corée du nord qui assure enchaîné les
essais avec succès quand la chine
mènerait des tests dans la plus grande
discrétion et les états unis qui essaie
de rattraper leur retard
enjeu de pouvoir sur cette menace du
futur ces armes si rapide et
indétectables qu'elle bouleverse la
course mondiale aux armements
c'était le 11 janvier pour commencer
l'année la corée du nord publie
triomphalement ces photos le troisième
lancement de ce qu'elle présente comme
son missile hypersonique à vol plané son
nom souveraineté et le grand leader kim
jong hoon a supervisé en personne
l'événement une première depuis des
années
impossible de savoir si ces missiles
sophistiqués sont vraiment opérationnel
mais le renforcement de l'arsenal
nord-coréen est condamné par les états
unis et procès armes menace les voisins
de la corée du nord et plus largement la
communauté internationale et le lard
choc mais les états unis ont pris du
retard dans la quête de ces armes
révolutionnaires notamment face à la
russie numéro un mondial de cette
technologie
des missiles qui peuvent slalomer
manoeuvrer ses larmes absolue selon
vladimir poutine dans sa quête de toute
puissance son objectif contourner les
systèmes de défense américains ces armes
change la donne stratégique
seller manoeuvrabilité qui va vraiment
compliqué la désignation de cibles
l'interception en tant que tel de ces
systèmes est donc le fait qu'il soit
manoeuvrant rend toute la manoeuvre
défensive beaucoup plus difficile les
américains s'inquiètent aussi de la
montée en puissance de la chine qui a
avancé masqué jusqu'au célébration des
70 ans de la république populaire en
pékin il a exhibé pour la première fois
ces missiles hypersonique à pointe
blanche d'aidé f10 est un test auraient
été réalisées l'été dernier la chine
démontre ses capacités de destruction
l'oeil tourner vers taïwan elle prouve
aussi la vulnérabilité des occidentaux
le système stable qui avait été mis en
place pendant la guerre froide et qui a
été progressivement détruit à la fin de
la guerre froide ce système explose avec
ces nouvelles armes qui rebattre
complètement les cartes en 2022 les
états unis investiront 600 milliards
d'euros pour moderniser leurs
équipements une priorité désormais en
europe la france planche sur dénis s'il
peut être opérationnel vers 2035 aucun
traité ne régit aujourd'hui la
prolifération des armes l'hypersonique
j'arrive quand est ce qu'on peut dire
effectivement qu'il ya une sorte de
héros nouveau nous nouvelle compétition
en fait un nouvelle course aux armements
il ya de toute façon une course aux
armements en asie je dirais presque
indépendamment de ce qui se passe avec
la corée du nord
aujourd'hui le budget militaire chinois
et de l'ordre parce qu'on n'est pas très
sûr des chiffres quand même de l'ordre
de 400 à 500 milliards de dollars le
budget coréens ou le budget japonais
sont de l'ordre de 40 à 45 ce qui est en
fait un niveau à peu près équivalent au
budget français oublient ou britanniques
est la question centrale jusqu'à présent
que dans les derniers mois qui était en
un en asie mineure était la question de
taiwan la question nord-coréenne
effectivement comme le disait un peu
interlocuteur était quelque part
passé de mode ou passer derrière de
surtout depuis l'arrivée du joe biden
cobayes dan était favorable à une
discussion avec les coréens mais ce
n'était pas avec les nord-coréens mais
ce n'était pas sa priorité sa priorité
comme chacun sait c'était le dialogue ou
la compétition sino-américaines et déjà
il a été obligé de s'intéresser à
d'autres affaires qui sont remontés sur
sa sur sa liste de priorités comme la
détention en europe de l'asile cren
l'état des négociations avec l'iran sur
le nucléaire et incidemment tout ce qui
se passe au proche orient est donc la
question nord-coréenne était une
question si j'ose dire à laisser si vous
me permettez l'expression à des employés
subalternes à des collaborateurs
subalternes donc là ça pourrait
peut-être changer frédéric charillon à
ce qu'il ya une nouvelle course aux
armements aujourd'hui avec ses missiles
à hypersonique oui d'abord il ya deux
choses
100 kg vous répond tout de suite qu'est
ce qu'il vient de dire non on va laisser
ça qui est très important aussi alors
sur l'aspect technique oui je crois
qu'il ya une course aux armements une
pause à la technologie on l'a vu votre
reportage a très bien dit il ya une cour
spéciale au bluff de la part de
plusieurs puissances qui annonce des
armes nouvelles révolutionnaire effet
d'annonce ils sont très très bien
orchestré une communication autour de ça
donc c'est à la fois une compétition
technique c'est une compétition
technologique oc et puis pour ce qu'on
vient de dire juste juste précédemment
la corée du nord effectivement fait
partie de ces pays qui reviennent en
haut de l'agenda de priorité
vous êtes tout à l'heure hayden a
remonté des sujets sur son agenda
politique et je crois que c'est ils
payent en quelque sorte les états unis
le prix d'une politique qui depuis
quelques mois visait à tout focaliser
sur l'affrontement américano chinois sur
la compétition avec la chine on a
beaucoup entendu
parler de cette priorité américaine déjà
ça fait un petit moment obama avec le
pivot américain vers l'asie avait déjà
donné cette impression le donald trump
et futurs baydan tous les deux ayant un
consensus bipartisans là-dessus aux
états unis on confirme et ça c'est à
dire toute notre priorité maintenant
c'est la chine nous allons bâtir nos
alliances en fonction de ça nous allons
demander à nos amis et de nous soutenir
sur ce point là c'est assez fréquent
états unis vient d'ailleurs que l'on se
focalise sur un sujet sur une grande
motivation collective sur une guerre ou
sur un adversaire en particulier sauf
que là avoir fait ça ça encourage à sa
nombre de pays à dire mais nous sommes
toujours là ne nous passaient pas par
pertes et profits et comme on disait
tout à l'heure on va faire savoir qu'on
a les moyens de s'imposer sur cette page
appelant le risque aujourd'hui
avec la russie sur l'ukraine celle que
la russie est aussi c'est aussi pour
elle une manière de nous dire ne croyez
pas que l'on va vers une nouvelle
bipolarité américano chinoises dont tous
les autres seraient exclues ou bas
serait effectivement en seconde division
des priorités nous sommes toujours là
nous avons les moyens on le voit quand
même de montrer la corée du nord fait
une démarche qui peut aussi s'assimiler
à ça le risque c'est qu'évidemment ça se
multiplient parce que rien ne nous dit
que d'autres puissances ailleurs au
proche orient ou ailleurs villain ne
viendront pas faire la même chose dans
les mois qui vient un général jean
vincent brisset vous êtes d'accord avec
ce que vient de dire justement fait avec
chariot est ce que d'abord il ya
effectivement une nouvelle course aux
armements avec cette nouvelle cette
nouvelle technologie est pourquoi les
etats-unis sont-ils en retard
alors
ces nouvelles technologies mais c'est
une course aux armements qui on a
tendance à exagérer à mon avis parce que
avant là avant cette technologie de
planeur hypersonique il y avait ce qu'on
appelle être multiples les têtes
indépendante multiples
entrées différé c'est à dire un seul
missile emmener un nombre important de
têtes nucléaires qui pouvait avoir des
trajectoires piloter et variable
alors effectivement ça n'a pas la zone
d'impact potentiel d'un planeur
hypersonique mais ça reste quelque chose
tient pratiquement aussi difficile sinon
plus difficile à intercepter une arme
hypersonique donc leurs échanges la
donne en terme de coursan moment est
rétabli ça ne change véritablement la
donne dans la mesure où les défenses les
défenses ont autant difficile contre ces
deux types d'armement sont légèrement
différentes le plan technologique mais
elles ont le même niveau de difficulté
donc ça va obliger les états unis à
aller jouer dans cette cour-là pour
obliger l'adversaire potentiel à
développer de du missile pour
intercepter peut-être ce genre de ce
genre de menaces mais je pense pas que
ça soit excessivement importants comme
comme différence je pense que les
différences beaucoup plus intéressante
sur le plan des matériels plus
conventionnel qui sont en train de
monter en puissance l'armée chinoise se
modernise mais on revient en ce sens on
n'a pas beaucoup de regards vers l'armée
japonaise par exemple l'armée japonaise
est en train de faire un bond qualitatif
énorme elle est sortie de cette force
d'autodéfense qui la liaient les mains
derrière le dos depuis des années et des
années comment justement se positionne
le japon à face à la chine et face
justement à la corée du nord et la corée
du sud à la le japon n'est plus le
considèrent que la chine n'est plus
simplement un compétiteur
économique mais le reste bien entendu
mais est surtout un rival stratégique
est en fait le japon a un problème
territorial avec la chine qui sont les
îles senkaku même il ya une petite île
qui est très très au sud des îles
senkaku qui est à 110 km des îles de de
l'île de taïwan et la chine revendique
en quelque sorte la place souveraineté
sur les senkaku et derrière la halle
affaires taïwanaises du point de vue
japonais il yal'affaire des senkaku
c'est à dire que l affaire des senkaku
et certainement pour le japon une ligne
rouge et il est certain que la chine
sait que c'est une ligne rouge mais
douce est justement ce nouvel arsenal du
côté japonais ils ont renforcé
effectivement leur foi soeur louis par
suler je pense aussi qu'il ya d'une
certaine manière
au fil des décennies j'allais presque
dire un non pas un doute mais une
incertitude sur le soutien américain
hank en cas de vrai conflit dans la zone
y compris peut-être sur taïwan
dans la mesure où les le japon à d'abord
vu les états unis si j'ose dire
abandonnez de get maman 75 pour pour
être plus actuelles abandonner
l'afghanistan et peut se poser la
question en tout cas les conservateurs
qui sont au pouvoir au japon est
actuellement c'est plutôt l'ale la plus
conservatrice est la plus concernée
nationaliste qui allie elle qui est en
fer de lance dans le gouvernement
japonais a tout intérêt à renforcer la
défense japonaise par rapport à la chine
et à ne pas simplement je grèce
abandonné aux bons soins des états unis
frédéric charillon là on venait de lire
poutine en plus est l'invité d'honneur
des jo de pékin les jo d'hiver qui
démarrent en fin de semaine en pleine
crise ukrainienne ilia en plus en
parallèle un rapprochement aujourd'hui
entre vladimir poutine et ainsi jean
ping oui alors c'est une erreur c'est
une interrogation sur rapprochement
parce que la question est de savoir
jusqu'où les deux souhaitent aller dans
le passé on a eu plusieurs fois des
rapprochement sino soviétique à l'époque
où sino russes qui ont souvent mal
tourné c'est à dire que il ya hélas on a
une vraiment une interrogation parce que
de toute évidence il ya une sorte de
complicité en tout cas il ya une
alliance objective entre les deux ces
deux grandes puissances ces deux énormes
puissances asiatiques pour gêner les
américains j'habite à chaque fois qu'il
s'agit effectivement de contrer l'agenda
occidentale l'agenda démocratique
libéral américain y compris d'ailleurs
pour soutenir des régimes que est aussi
occidentaux cherchent au contraire à
critiquer ils sont ensemble mais
jusqu'où c'est la question que tout le
monde se pose parce que la russie n'a
pas non plus intérêt à se mettre
totalement entre les mains et
l'économique commercial de la chine et
donc il ya un dilemme la d1000 abouti là
il ya effectivement une quelque chose à
tirer de cette alliance possible avec
pékin pour pour revenir dans le jeu la
condition que ce soit vraiment pour
revenir dans le jeu pas pour se mettre
entre les mains de de pékin parce que le
rapport de force s'est complètement
inversée entre les années 50 où le grand
frère soviétique faisait figure de faim
était la figure tutélaire des pays
communistes qui adoube est en quelque
sorte la chine nouvellement communiste
après la victoire de mao et aujourd'hui
le rapport de force s'est inversé
aujourd'hui la chine c'est une
démographie beaucoup plus importante
c'est une puce est la deuxième puissance
économique
la russie est très loin de ça donc ça
n'est pas non plus dans l'intérêt de la
russie de se mettre entre le magazine et
juste une petite précision on parlait du
japon il ya un instant c'est une région
l'asie qui est l'une de celles qui bat
le record de puissance nucléaire
puisqu'on à la russie on à la chine on à
la corée du nord a très loin on à l'inde
on a évidemment la puissance américaine
qui est très présente dans la région et
face à ça le japon lui on le sait pour
des raisons historiques évidentes les
bombes atomique de 1945 et en plus cela
l'accident nucléaire de 2011 rejette
complètement le nucléaire et ça c'est
une donne importante je suis tout à fait
d'accord sur ce qui a été dit sur le la
modernisation de l'armée japonaise mejia
cette limite c'est dire que si dans
n'importe quel autre cas dans notre
région du monde à notre pays serait face
à cela veut dire que cette puissance
chinoise qui monde on dirait l'une des
solutions c'est peut-être de songer à la
dissuasion
le japon seul interdit complètement ça
aussi c'est une donne extrêmement
importante dans la région général jean
vincent brisset on a vu dans le
reportage de nos confrères de france
télévision qu'est la france développé
également des missiles hypersonique est
ce que c'est le cas ça serait plutôt à
l'horizon 2030 2035 c'est important
stratégiquement pour la france
à partir du moment où cette course était
lancée les grands pays qui développent
de l'armement stratégique
indépendamment
développons des planeur hypersonique est
là la france fait partie de ces plaies
de ses très rares pays donc elle va
développer les planeur hypersonique
c'est quelque chose si vous voulez
qu'ils aient les débuts de développement
qu'on va pas dans la la réalisation
pratique et l'expérimental enfin les
essais grandeur nature l'hypersonique
c'est quelque chose qui est relativement
facile à développer en petit comité
s'est passé beaucoup de calculs c'est
beaucoup de décès en soufflerie mais de
ma tête il n'y a pas il n'y a pas encore
de grands de grands programmes qu'ils
soient nécessaires par contre il est
évident que il faut aller plus loin que
de la veille simplement et commencer à
développer techniquement quelques
quelques petits matériels jouez et
gagnez aussi que sylvia l'édile a que le
japon s'interdit le nucléaire c'est vrai
que politiquement le japon s'interdit
nucléaire il ya quand même on a toujours
suivi si vous voulez dans l'est j'ai
fait partie des forces nucléaires en
france on a toujours suivi les
développements d'un certain nombre de
pays des potentialités d'un certain
nombre de pays parce que taiwan par
exemple un programme nucléaire militaire
qui l'a abandonné et le japon conserve
la capacité de produire extrêmement
rapidement 1h20 nucléaire et le fait par
exemple qu'il ya dans une université
japonaise encore une chaire de détonique
qui est une des sciences nécessaires à
la mise au point d'une arme nucléaire
est un révélateur du fait que le japon
se l'interdît oui mais le japon garde
techniquement quand même une petite
soirée entre ouvert au chaos ok ou jean
yves caullet pour en revenir justement à
cette péninsule
coréenne on se souvient justement que le
président sud coréen lui avait fait tout
un ensemble de démarches avec kim
jong-un pour en fait faire en sorte pas
d'avoir à traiter de paiement fait
qu'une sorte de deux lignes de
démarcation se souvient une sorte de
pacification en tout cas entre les deux
entre la corée du nord la corée du
séjour ou est-ce que ça pour vous
prouver ce que ça en est et est-ce qu
effectivement ces nouvelles menaces de
kim jong-un vous remettre en question
aurait tout sera progressivement tout ce
qui a précédé les rencontres les deux
rencontres entre trump et kim jong-un
mais il est important de souligner qu'à
partir de l'automne dernier en septembre
lorsqu'il est aller aux nations unies le
président moo-jin a relancé le débat
elle a proposé à la corée du nord de
laon de rente de lancer une négociation
en vue d'un traité de paix vous savez
qu'il ya pas eu de il n'y a pas eu très
peur les puissances belligérantes et
qu'on est toujours sur un armistice qui
date de 1953 il a fait 7 il a fait cette
déclaration qui a été accueillie par
certains en corée du nord de manière
négative en dix ans les etats-unis
gardent une politique hostile la soeur
de kim jong-un à elf une déclaration
disant que c'était une déclaration
admirable qui a peu surpris tout le
monde et dissonant oui dissonante dans
les villes ce qui montre d'ailleurs
toujours le côté un peu souffler le
chaud soufflé le froid de la part des
nord coréens
ce projet de mme jean a continué il ya
eu des rencontres entre sud coréens
américains chaque fois le sujet a été
j'irai indiqué il l'arrêt indiqué le 3
janvier dernier lorsqu'il est intervenu
à la télévision dans le cadre de son
allocation allocution de nouvel an et il
l'a dit canberra donc mme jean et lui
extrêmement partisan de lancer
négociations à 3 toujours malgré donc la
mu pique à son bras c'est à dire corée
du sud corée du nord états-unis ou à 4
en incluant la chine c'est entre
guillemets c'est aux parties à
s'entendre et c'est là qu'est le fond de
la faire c'est à dire que pour qui une
négociation entre avec la corée du nord
il faut qu'il y ait une qui ont une
confiance réciproque entre les parties
or aujourd'hui et depuis toujours il ya
une méfiance réciproque cette référence
elle est d'autant plus forte que la
corée du nord lancent des missiles les
états unis réagissent en je dirais de
manière négative c'est à ces lancements
et chine alors attendez ils ont ils ont
ils ont damman suite nommé un
ambassadeur en corée du sud qui est
plutôt un un bout de feu qu'un
négociateur favorable à la reprise des
négociations la chine de son côté je
dirais volontiers de la chine ce qu'on
disait de certains hommes politiques ou
femmes politiques en europe dans les
années 90 la chine elle aime tellement
la corée que si en à 2,7 c'est très bien
pour elle ça les arrange ça l'arrangé
d'avoir un état tampon le problème de
cet état tampon c'est qu'il n'est pas
très facilement contrôlable y compris
par les chinois eux mêmes parce que la
république de corée du nord est un état
qui perd nationalistes ce nationalisme
il s'exerce à l'encontre des états unis
à l'encontre du japon à cause du
passéisme du passé mais aussi à
l'encontre de la chine n'ont pas envie
d'être un état vassal en quelque sorte
donc la chine et dans une aussi dans une
situation assez difficile assez délicate
pour manoeuvrer avec la corée du nord
frédéric charillon à ce que les jo de
pékin seront une occasion justement de
pour la chine d'abord de montrer au
monde qu'elle peut effectivement les
organiser malgré la crise du coc vide
mais peut-être avec ce rapprochement de
l'ue avec vladimir poutine d'un côté de
provoquer peut-être les états unis 2 ou
au contraire d'inviter les coréens à se
rapprocher est-ce que ça va être un
moment diplomatique
c'est toujours un petit peu un monde
diplomatique et jeux olympiques mais
sauf que là ça peut être aussi un moment
de crispation diplomatique on se
souvient du boycott des jeux olympiques
de moscou en 1980 et là il ya un boycott
diplomatique qui s'organise de la part
des pays occidentaux sur les jeux
olympiques de pékin c'est à dire que on
ne remet pas en cause la participation
des athlètes des ou des sportifs en
revanche ont remis en cause la présence
politique de hauts responsables au
l'ouverture ou dans ou dans ces jeux
donc ce qui est davantage probable cessé
de marquer clairement les camps entre
ceux qui ne veulent pas être présent
diplomatiquement politiquement pour les
cérémonies et ce au contraire qu'ils
vont être les invités d'honneur et
qu'ils vont être mis en avant ce qui va
permettre à la chine de montrer qu'elle
a un camp peut-être derrière elle alors
c'est un beau ce qui manque aujourd'hui
la chine à apparaître véritable allié au
sein de ces institutionnels du terme et
donc ça peut être un moment
effectivement diplomatique important il
se joue des parties diplomatique très
très complexe en ce moment en asie parce
que on on vient d'évoquer la relation
corée du nord chine qui effectivement
est complexe parce que la chine est le
principal soutien de la corée bien c'est
d'ailleurs peut-être un facteur qui fait
que l'accord dit non à poursuivre encore
très longtemps ces tirs de missiles pour
ne pas être gêné l'ouverture de ne pas
mettre en difficulté son allié chinois
puisque la corée du nord n'a pas
beaucoup de pays qui le soutient donc la
chine est le principal ce sera peut-être
pas le moment le continuer avec gênés
par ce genre de ce genre d'initiative
mais mes relations on vient de le dire
elle est très compliqué pour la corée du
sud la corée du sud aussi a des
relations très compliquées d'abord avec
les états unis qui son principal soutien
il ya beaucoup de troupes qui sont les
américaines qui sont en corée du sud
pour protéger la corée du sud - la corée
du sud et arrêté à plusieurs reprises
gêné par les initiatives américaines
soit sous trump avec le qui m'avait avec
qui mais son essai entrevue là tous les
deux soient pas à la politique
américaine vis-à-vis de l'alliance
dans le pacifique et ses déclarations
très dures vis-à-vis de la chine et puis
la corée du sud a aussi un autre
problème ces relations et au japon
lorsque on pourrait penser que si on
s'achemine quand ils sont de
consolidation du camp démocratique en
asie on pourrait retrouver corée du sud
taiwan japon inde encore que l'inde a
aussi une petite dérive nationaliste on
pourrait imaginer qu'on est tout cela et
pour le japon l'une des sages obligé
c'est évidemment se rapprocher de la
corée du sud et c'est difficile très
difficile pour des raisons historiques
la pole voilà après des raisons de
mémorielle pour les griefs que la corée
du sud a gardé vis-à-vis du japon depuis
la seconde guerre mondiale et même les
années antérieures les exigences des
excuses de la part de la corée du sud le
japon n'apprécie pas beaucoup pour
toutes ces raisons il ya un jeu qui
devrait être finalement plus plus clair
entre démocratie autoritarisme et qui
est singulièrement compliquée par des
questions bilatérales souvent d'ailleurs
historique mémorial est très très très
ancienne et démocratie n'a pas forcément
les mêmes intérêts non plus général jean
vincent brisset jusqu'où peut aller
cette escalade est ce qu on est
aujourd'hui dans un contexte de
sécuritaire d' escalade course aux
armements
hypersonique et autres
je pense que dans le coin de la l'accord
est affalé corée japon
et chine pour le moment il n'y a pas de
ya pas de risque immédiat il ya un point
chaud potentiel était quand même
beaucoup plus seul taiwan pour quelque
chose qui pourrait être une agression
organisée par la chine vis-à-vis de
taïwan ça c'est quelque chose qui peut
arriver un peu n'importe quand si la
chine le décide et uniquement si la
chine ne décide il ya quelque chose que
je crains beaucoup plus depuis des
années c'est le risque d'un accident ou
d'un incident provoqué qui dégénérerait
en mer de chine du sud en particulier il
ya eu en 2001 un avion américain avec 14
personnes à bord qui a été abordé parce
qu'un pilote chinois avaient des
problèmes de qualité technique de
pilotage et a voulu faire une
démonstration qui s'est soulevée par sa
mort mais par l'obligation cet avion
chinois que se posaient sur
annan il ya eu des collisions ou des
collisions manqué autres bateaux
bâtiments militaires
américains et bâtiments militaires
chinois qui harcelait les bâtiments
américains si quelque chose devait
provoquer la mort de marat japonais
oumara américain où marat occidentaux il
est possible que là on n'ait augmenté
violente du risque et qui serait pas une
montée violente d'un risque nucléaire je
pense mais une montée violente d'un
risque de blocage de blocus un ou deux
prises de prise de gage d'un pays sur un
autre risque de blocage possible j'en ai
quand même vous êtes d'accord avec ce
gamin de génération à fait celle ci
parle beaucoup des tensions autour de
l'ukraine mais est ce que finalement
l'étincelle pour est revenu il veut nous
avons un dérapage je vous donne un autre
exemple qui peut paraître un peu
anecdotique de vue de paris mais au mois
de décembre
l'ancien premier ministre japonais
shinzo abe était à taïwan pour une
conférence et il a notamment indiqué que
s'il y avait eu un incident maritime
dans le détroit de taiwan et bien le
japon serait forcément partie prenante
de cet incident de cet incident et
devrait réagir ce qui a valeur de taiwan
en faveur de taiwan est des états unis
ce qui a fait évidemment sursauté puis
je dis ça poliment sursauter pékin qui a
protesté donc vous voyez c'est un sujet
qui peut exister en mer du en mer de
chine du sud qui peut exister dans le
détroit de taiwan qui peut exister ce
que ce que je disais auparavant autour
des îles senkaku c'est donc un quelque
chose de qui est sérieux mais ce set jo
baidhani ray jusqu'à intervenir c'est
effectivement il y avait sachez dire est
aujourd'hui incapable de lire dans le
marc de café et de vous dire ce qu'il
ferait d'abord jeu est-ce que c'est
montrer parce qu'on a on a le tort de
voir simplement
là l'action de la chine par rapport à
taïwan comme une sorte d' invasion
militaire maritime il peut y avoir des
tas de moyens y compris par là lassé des
cyber attaques qui visent une forme d
étouffement progressif de l'île de
taïwan qui l'amène quelque part à
demander le rattachement du point de vue
chinois le rattachement de taiwan à la
chine il ya l'option militaire n'est
certainement pas la seule envisagée et
mais je pense que par rapport aux essais
militaires que vous essaierez qui sont
actuellement en cours ils vont encore
continuer un certain temps pour au moins
une raison c'est que à la mi février il
y aura de grandes parades militaires
pyongyang pour célébrer ont célébré hier
certes du père de kim jong-il kim
jong-il et au mois d'avril
c'est le numéro vert du grand père donc
c'était bien
divers qui dans lequel il peut y avoir
des effets je pense ou six parce que
sassou de la population autour du chef
je ne sais pas si ça soude la population
parce que personne ne sait vraiment ce
que pense la population nord-coréenne et
donc je évidemment ça soude je dirais la
nomenclature à militaires autour de de
kim jong-un skip essentiel pour lui très
déjà à la gloire oui oui et mais je
pense aussi qu'un autre une autre étape
qui est importante par rapport à ces
sujets c'est qui va être le prochain
président de corée du sud aujourd'hui il
ya deux candidats qui sont un peu à
égalité ils ont 33 34% dans les sondages
d'opinion chacun l'un est conservateur
s'appelle youn il est plutôt c'est un
avocat enfin procureur plus tôt et c'est
pas un expert militaire ou un expert
stratège mais c'est les positions qu'ils
indiquent aujourd'hui sont très
conservatrices c'est celle de la fermeté
il a même parlé mais c'est un peu être
un un tic je dirais électoraliste de
first strike et l'autre candidat est
plus proche de monsieur moon il
s'appelle monsieur l'iss d'un progress 6
mais il n'est pas certain qu'il soit
aussi entre guillemets bienveillant que
light et moon par rapport avec rudy nord
donc en fait je pense qu'il y aura à
affluer sur sa télé le sens gagne au
walmart flux également en corée du sud
votre réaction frédéric charillon les
états unis on pourra revenir à joe biden
qu'on a peu entendu justement face à la
corée du nord est ce que tout d'un coup
ils pourraient se réintéresser
indépendamment de la chine à la corée du
nord en particulier joe biden et à la
corée du sud à la corée tout court oco
indépendamment indépendamment de la
chine c'est difficile parce que
précisément la vue l'obsession
américaine c'est la chine et ça a même
poussé les états unis à des décisions
douloureuses on se souvient du du
retrait arguant tout ça et d'une sorte
de mise en cohérence de la politique
étrangère américaine qui considère que
vraiment le défi aujourd'hui
le défi pour lequel il faut vraiment
garder ses forces et sauvegarder toutes
ses ressources et lacombe ce qu'il pense
que c'est du bluff du coup ces tirs de
missiles de qui nous on good parce que
c'est tout de même quand il y en a sept
le même où pendant le même mois non mais
tout va être
alors c'est tout tout tout l'enjeu de se
battre rc que les états unis voudraient
tout ramener à la question chinoise et
notamment d'ailleurs pour la corée du
sud c'est à dire on va vous protéger
mais surtout vous êtes avec nous contre
contre la chine s'il se passait quelque
chose à taiwan et du côté de la corée du
nord précisément tout l'enjeu c'est de
se démarquer de cette obsession chinoise
américaine pour pour essayer de négocier
ses propres ses propres intérêts donc là
il ya une c'est pour ça que j'étais tout
à l'heure je crois que les etats unis se
sont un type piéger en affirmant aussi
aux efforts qu'ils ont faits que leur
principale priorité aujourd'hui c'était
la chine parce que ça les oblige c'est
cohérent de certaines manières de dire
voilà on a identifié un défi principal
on va donc s'aligner sur ce défi
principal mais ça ne convient à tous les
autres de montrer qu'ils existent et du
coup pour les états unis ça va être un
véritable casse tête parce que de temps
en temps il répond à récupérer la
priorité chinoise en disant bon très
bien on s'occupe de vous mais alors vous
êtes avec nous s'il se passe quelque
chose en asie et dans d'autres cas ce
sera absolument impossible de faire le
lien entre les deux sujets et donc ils
vont devoir courir plusieurs lièvres à
la fois général jean vincent brisset ce
qu on est finalement très très loin
d'une période qu'on a pu connaître
pendant la détente dans les années
soixante dix où effectivement on est et
où il y avait des accords de désarmement
de désescalade globaux entre la russie
et les etats unis est-ce qu'on est très
loin de cette période
alors qu'on en est sorti
on est passé d'un d'une époque où
c'était beaucoup dans le déclaratif à
une époque où maintenant on arrive parce
que le renseignement a beaucoup changé
on arrive à savoir tout sur sur l'autre
donc on gesticule de manière à être vus
par les satellites de l'autre on
gesticule
de manière à faire du renseignement
électronique a donné lieu à du
renseignement électronique donc les deux
la fin de tous les camps sont beaucoup
plus au courant de ce qui se passe chez
l'autre qu'il ne l'était avant donc
c'est dangereux ou pas alors c'est plus
dangereux je ne pense pas que ça soit
plus un joint au contraire dans la
mesure où on a l'information
avec un peu de recul on ne risque pas la
taxe surprise modèle pearl harbour
ça s'est terminé les délais de
préparation et les délais de
transmission de l'information sont
devenues telles tellement court que on
arrive à savoir avec suffisamment de
préavis ce qui peut se passer de l'autre
côté donc on a on a changé de mentalité
on a changé de manière de voir
l'adversaire et le c'est intéressant de
voir ce qui se passe en ukraine à
l'heure actuelle où on explique tous les
jours que les rues seront massés des
forces que les russes ont rajouté ceux
ci ont rajouté cela alors qu'on sait
très bien que en fait ils n'ont pas
désengagé des forces qui étaient
présentes depuis longtemps et que seul
où les mouvements sont relativement
limités par rapport à ce qui restait sur
place depuis 2014 donc qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire qu'on est dans le discours
mais bon on est beaucoup dans le
discours ça a commencé on parlait tout à
l'heure du pivot qui avait été décrétée
par obama le pivot d'obama c'est resté
un discours creux pendant huit ans et
vis à vis à vis de la corée du nord ont
la patience stratégique ça a consisté à
laisser faire à la corée du nord tout ce
qu'elle voulait on est passé à une
époque où on est passé d'un discours qui
restait discours un bras de fer
extrêmement dure entre trump et la corée
du nord et la chine parce que la chine a
laissé tomber à l'époque de trump la
chine a laissé tomber la corée du nord
très largement et accepter des sanctions
contre la corée du nord il aurait
toujours refusé
et maintenant il ya une période de
largement une période de test vis-à-vis
de bailleurs dame qui a suivi la
politique de trump vis-à-vis de la chine
tout en voulant la rendre multilatéral
alors que trump et et orbi latéral pure
avec la chine bayonne a voulu faire du
multilatéral et s'associer d'autres pays
danser dans sa dureté vis-à-vis de la
chine
vis-à-vis de la corée du nord c'est un
petit peu différent parce que c'est
beaucoup plus lointain pour des alliés
potentiels des états unis voilà
justement un dernier mot sur la corée du
nord donc il va y avoir cet anniversaire
au mois de mars mois de mars vous pensez
que valeur d'autres tirs a priori est-ce
qu'ils vont est ce que ça change la
donne en fait ce qui se passe dans ce
que ça ne change pas grandement la donne
en fait le problème actuel c'est de
pouvoir relancer les négociations et
comme je le disais auparavant d'avoir un
minimum de confiance réciproque de
trouver un format a3 ou a4 et à trouver
des interlocuteurs car kim était
effectivement extrêmement satisfait de
sa rencontre avec trump qui pour lui
était une reconnaissance or à l'évidence
jobs hayden n'a pas l'intention de
rencontrer kim et il se satisferait
d'une négociation qui passerait par la
corée du sud et par rapport est avec les
collaborateurs du département d'état
donc on a encore sur des prémisses d'une
possible table de négociation avec la
corrida et de changer attentes en action
- maintenant ce qu'attend rallye se dit
lui c'est la levée des sanctions parce
qu'il n'a certainement pas l'intention
d'abandonner son programme militaire et
nucléaire en revanche il a un besoin
urgent de lever les sanctions car son
économie s'effondre merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nos j'arrive cola merci
à vous frédéric charillon merci général
jean vincent brisset d'avoir participé à
cette émission merci à vous tous de nous
avoir suivis et reste avec nous sur
france 24